oh it's great to be here tell me the
letter or in your name locks yeah where
did that come from it's not really an
English letter well when I thought about
creating this project I use my middle
name which is Lapsley
and I wanted to have something that was
slightly different it's kind of like an
alter ego and the name Scottish and I
kind of thought you know blond hair I
probably come from Scandinavia somewhere
so I under there and also when you look
at a list of words on a on a piece of
paper if a word has an accent you're
instantly drawn to it so yeah I feel
like I should be like oh I was born in
Norway and my parents are from have you
ever been here before ever yeah I played
in Gothenburg actually which is probably
one of the best crowds I've ever had so
how do you have an idea of Scandinavian
style is that is that a term for you is
that something yeah I mean you're all
gorgeous
you think this is has he found the
Scandinavian style you think laughing
thank you
you can stroke me later do people have I
mean you you travel a lot and you see
Scandinavia from outside do you people
foreigners see Scandinavians as a
stylish in general as a as a stylish
stylish people you think actually I
think this Swedes the women are very
well known to be beautiful they don't
say so much about that about Norwegians
or Danish but mostly Scandinavia is one
country you know in Stockholm is
somewhere in order they don't know very
much about Scandinavia except for the
name I feel no the men in Copenhagen the
men in yeah they have like bears and
little tortoiseshell glasses somewhat
similar vibe that's what you like the
men opening
well III think this is this is primarily
a Norwegian Swedish show so yeah yeah
yeah well associations I have to add
when you ask if we are known to be
stylish that when I was very famous in
United States eight years in a row
I was on the list of the worst dress
worst dress worst and the terrible thing
my best friend she got my clothes you
know asked me itself and everybody said
- oh you're so beautiful so it was the
way I was wearing it worse dress so it
wasn't about Kosovo's about you it was
my style wasn't stylish for the club
I've always been an American thing yeah
well then all that cool tell you your
master plan wasn't to be a pop star was
it oh no it was like you were a student
right yeah I finished my a-levels and
then suddenly I had some emails like you
know maybe you can do this as a career
we can we can see something big coming
from this and it was quite intimidating
especially when the music that you make
is is for yourself and I only had a
bedroom studio set up and it's really
scary someone telling you like oh we
want to sign a record deal or you know
we can see you in big lights or whatever
was there I don't know some people have
this moment this is an epiphany where
they realize they have a talent was it
like that for you or was it more like
gradually realizing you have a great
work voice you have a great talent I
mean it was always an interest
I've definitely included more vocals
over the years and in my in my songs I
never had singing lessons or or anything
like that because it was never
encouraged to follow that pursue I think
now I've grown in confidence and so I've
developed and become a singer when I
wasn't before this thing with with the
voice it's very I mean it's it's
very distinct what what that does I mean
it's it's a very much part of your
identity the singing voice and so is I
think the talking was and you have a
very distinct voice I know which is a
very I'm not in a bad way I mean not in
a bad way but it's a great part of your
identity
and it's funny because - as well but I
never listen to my voice I mean but I
the thing of the things you hate the
things I hate you don't school lightly
teeth but me voice and me glasses are
now my trademark it's the things that
people so I love you for or like you for
so it's that very weird weird thing with
the voice but singing wise I can only I
can either do Barry why there's no in
between a cat so karaoke I forego Kate
Bush bee gees or like I wanna make love
to you there's nothing between oh you
know so it's so it's funny our weights
of me voice yeah it's like at the
beginning oh so soft cotton because I
used to ring up for jobs and peopled
laughing you think they don't realize
that it's all right now but in that
early bit you know it was often and I
started getting quite insular getting
cry I found myself not a part is talking
and sort of stand-ups giving me that
kind of kind of confidence because some
people is gonna jar with some people
some people oh that voice because I even
I can't stand you know it's like a sago
trapped in a lift oh oh we do you say
karaoke later yeah what you're you you
also have a very characteristic way yes
and I didn't have a faintest idea about
that before I I did my first television
program and everybody's just talked
about my voice and I thought I had it
totally normally was in total normally
dialect and people start asking where
you got that from and what is your dial
don't know I'm grown up outside
Stockholm it's it must be something with
it I didn't know what it is but but but
all people have talked a lot about my
way to speak
do you watch yourself on television yes
I love watching myself but I mean when I
hear me speaking I think it sounds
totally normally I mean because I'm so
used to it I love it absolutely you know
when you go when you go abroad if I go
to America people sort of say where are
you from and you go Northampton and of
course they imagine everyone in that
town you actually did a musical on
Broadway yes which launches last musical
and the in here he wrote it for me and I
really told him I cannot dance and I
cannot sing absolutely and he was very
old he was sitting at the piano and he
said oh no one can really sing you know
I make melodies for them and and then I
said well and then he said just sing
happy birthday and and the old man sat
there and started and I sang happy
birthday he aged and I did the musical
but you know it was not a huge success
right well it was sold out in front
because I was so popular but when all
the in front was bought then it didn't
go but I had trouble also with my voice
here in Norway only because they always
made parodies about me my sad crying
voice and I didn't understand it and I
was on the talk show like this in Norway
and he said no we will show you a lot of
parodies on you and that was very sad
for me and I
to see one parody after another and they
were all bad and I said that and then
came one you know making something about
the potato whatever that is good and it
was me I didn't recognize me we have
actually this Norwegian parody of this
show going viral
yes and it's it's the first I mean it's
it's the first time I've been really
hurt you know yeah because it's so
bloody good it's like - I continue to
have you have been called the new face
of the power ballad oh yeah I've heard
that yes do you like that is it is
obviously a compliment you know um don't
know if I've got any power ballads yeah
but this thought you got to do for us
tonight tell no one um yeah I rated this
year it was it was one of the last songs
on the album vibro so it's quite fresh
yeah it's about someone being blind to a
relationship ending so I hope you enjoy
lovely your about this waiting thank you
so much for being mostly thank you very
much and star you which is lying here
which is lying in what your speaking has
nothing to do with the voice or anything
really
yeah have you been drinking